[music]
We have Eran Rostami the CTO of Volulti
which are building the AI for chip and
electronics design serving
semiconductors industry. Thanks for
having you here man.
>> Of course pleasure to be here. Good
afternoon Paris.
>> Do you want to do like a short
introduction of yourself? I think you're
doing it best.
>> Sounds good. Uh hey everyone. Uh my name
is Aron. always having fun. Uh started
Voltai two years ago. Uh with the belief
that infrastructure is the barebone for
everything in AI. I was a researcher at
Stanford University. Later I worked at a
semiconductor company called Cyber
Systems. They built a wafer skill chip
as big as my head and that gave the
passion to basically figure out how can
we use uh reasoning models intelligence
for designing complex
electronics and semiconductors and glad
to be here.
>> Yeah man I think that's a great
introduction. We've got some challenging
questions too.
>> Go for it
>> for you. So let me start with the so
we've got the three sections for this
panel. First of all will be the
invisible bottleneck of hardware where
we will be explaining about like what
are the challenges when it comes to
designing hardware. Second AI native
chip design
let's talk about chips that AI
>> we can talk about that
>> and the third one will be what it means
for the physical AI builders. I would
love you to expand and go more into
details in that topic but let's start
with the invisible bottleneck of
hardware. So the first question like you
know you're a CTO of a company building
AI for one of the most technically
complex domains right on earth
semiconductor and electronics design. So
the question would be for the people in
this room and most of them are actually
building in the physical AI space and
systems why should they care about what
happens earlier in this talk.
>> So the question is what why should you
care about the electronics and
semiconductors?
Um
couple years ago when I started a
company the belief was that
um
everything that we touch from automotive
rockets medical devices and most
importantly nowadays AGI these are all
things in my view bottlenecked by our
abilities in innovating at the hardware
layer. And fast forward three years
later, we see that the world's most
valuable company, Nvidia, is a is a
semiconductor company. Had you just
invested then, you would have been rich
by now. And the companies in this space
who focus on this critical bottleneck
have gone to change not just the economy
but also countries. TSMC has changed
Taiwan, Shenzhen has changed Taiwan, uh
has changed China, Nvidia is changing
United States. And I believe that for
the next frontier as well for I guess
robotics the folks who are going to be
focusing on the very low level the most
complex part of the stack which is the
intelligence that runs on the hardware
the electronics and semiconductors
that's the part that would be the
critical bottleneck and whoever who's
building in that will be the guess most
uh fortunate as well [clears throat]
benefit from it.
>> Yeah.
Um
I guess that uh and until 2030 2031
my prediction is that the world is going
to be uh mostly move away from being
bottlenecked by power being bottlenecked
by silicon and I guess TSMC being the
biggest choke hole for the world
continues to be one while we have
addressed many other bottlenecks and I
think that would be also true for
robotics Well, we have solved all the
problems in the mechanical design. We
have solved all the problems within the
actuators. But then all of these
mechanical aspects are the wrapper for
the electronics part of it. And
I think what Elon is doing with Terrafab
is the right thing to focus on where
long-term that is probably going to be
the world's most valuable company.
>> Okay.
Fair enough. You know right now when you
look at the appliance and devices like
all of them are labeled with the AI
stamp on it like what does really an AI
breakthrough in hardware design actually
look like from your perspective from the
CTO perspective?
>> Great question. So one right now when
you look at the design process uh
traditionally takes about three years
and this is why a lot of the I guess the
silicon providers and hardware companies
need to do the job of predicting the
future that the hardware that you're
building today is it going to be
relevant 3 years from now or not four
years from now or not but then uh the
reason that it takes so long to design
It is uh the manufacturing process
actually takes about 6 to 8 months but
the majority of the those three-year
period is spent on making sure that
whatever you're designing is correct.
The amount of logic is very dense and is
very little but if there is a bug we're
talking about billions of dollars in
recall of the hardware silicon and
electronics that you've designed and
then recalling them. So how about
we can reduce that three-year timeline
into 9 month into 5 month where we no
longer have to play the guess of where
are the workloads are going to go into
the future where are the model
architectures are going to be what is
the demand going to look like where we
can enter a more reactant a a reactive
mode where whenever we see an
architecture a model architecture that's
I
uh getting more popular being the VAS,
the VLMs and energy based models,
diffusion models and all of that. We can
change the underlying hardware as fast
as possible. So we can like deploy that
to have the most efficient hardware to
run the most efficient model. Um
that is that is a paradigm that the
world has not seen. To put it into
perspective, imagine
when we built the internet, updating a
website would take three years.
What would the world would look like
today? I don't I don't think we will be
here if updating a website was like
this. It would take three years. But
this is how it is in the hardware world
where the next generation of uh kyber
that we're talking about ultra rubin
racks that we're talking about are going
to like take 3 4 years to get out there
and then get updated. This is why I
believe that the world is fundamentally
bottlenecked by our abilities to iterate
and innovate fast at the hardware layer
which is ultimately also limiting our
ability to innovate at the model
intelligence architecture.
Okay. Um, I think we are in a great
space where people really get what
you're talking about, especially in the
physical AI space. I mean, these people
are used to iterate over hardware, which
is not as easy as iterating over
software, of course. So, I I'm sure they
got your point very well.
>> Yeah. I mean I think the other mental
model to adopt here is that the ultimate
user of these whatever we're building
here being the models we're training the
robots we're building the data centers
we're uh commissioning are actually not
going to be humans the ultimate user are
going to be the agents and the
intelligence
and that's when we enter a world of
infinite usage where we're no longer
bottlenecked our abilities in the number
of people who could instantiate the
agents to go do the work but an agent
could instantiate a thousand sub agent
under itself to do the job to do the
task and I think that's the part that
where the hardware becomes the
bottleneck
and the models as well do the
architecture exploration on what is the
best model to train what is the best
intelligence to to discover rather than
humans
And after that the other the way we have
seen in scaling loss uh there is the
number of parameters that matter is the
amount of data that matters. A lot of it
now the world is running out on data
that is available on the internet and we
are relying on verifiable domains to
generate data that practically will be
better than humans and I think that
would be the ultimate test for
intelligence where we're no longer bound
by the quality of the proprietary data
that you collect from enterprises or
humans but actually we can generate the
data uh based on the fundamentals of
physics.
and the first principles of the world
and that is going to be all dominated by
also the compute layer where the compute
is going to be the biggest contributor
of generating highquality data better
than what humans can do. So both at the
intelligence layer where the where the
agents will do the model exploration
will discover new architectures and also
at the data layer. Uh I think that's
kind of like where the infinite there is
going to be infinite demand for
inference for hardware but then the the
world is going to be bottlenecked by
silicon.
>> Okay. Um let's go back to the second
part about the AI native chip design.
Can you walk us through a specific
concrete example of where AI native
design tools change the outcome in
actual hardware timelines?
>> Great question. U
I'm pretty sure you guys all familiar
with companies like Brock. They're a two
trillion dollar company. Um,
actually not a lot of people know what
they do. They're very secretive about
what they do. Uh, they're most well
known for taking care of physical
design, for building the AI accelerators
for some of the world's most smartest
companies.
We're talking about the TPUs designed by
Google. We're talking about jalapeno
design by open AAI where they take care
of the front end and the logical design
aspect of things while a lot of the
backend and the physical design when you
have the logic you need to turn it into
like physical implementation at the
foundaries is mostly done by Broadcom.
Why is that the case?
When you look at the
node processes from TSMC for seven
nanometer and below,
the error rate that you see produced by
the simulation tools is about 15 to 20%.
error rate. Meaning that uh whenever you
have a standard cell and you have
voltage going through the metal that
excites the metal creates an
electrostatic field around itself. You
can almost be sure that most often time
when you like manufacture that piece of
hardware it's going to have 20% error
rate that it's actually wrong. And a
company like Broadcom has decades of
experience of manufacturing these
things. So they know the guard bands in
the design process that how far they can
push the limits on the physical design
before they start failing where they
produce a silicon that is actually not
functional and doesn't bring up or has
crazy parasitics and RC extraction RC
problems.
They have that they have
capitalized on that knowledge and the IP
that they've developed around this.
Hence why they have an advantage to be a
$2 trillion company. And I believe that
when it comes to being an AI native
workflow, how does it change that
process is when we can reduce that error
rate and the architecture exploration
that you do to less than 1%.
the possibility of you turning the logic
when you to the physical design and then
having an error when you can do direct
numerical simulation with AI that allows
for higher fidelity and higher degrees
of freedom of simulation and for the AI
to be able to do the all the ex
exploration around the architecture to
get to an error rate than less than 1%
is going to enable designs in the future
in a way that the world has not seen yet
because the current status quo operates
on a 15 to 20% error rate but then if we
can reduce that to 1%.
We're going to see a lot of exciting
designs.
>> Okay man, perfectly summarized. Thanks
so much. Um considering we have so many
physical AI builders and robotics
builders here, I would love to focus a
little bit on them in the last part of
our session. So to all the founders and
the engineers from the physical AI space
building humanoids, building industrial
robots and physical AI systems, what
should they understand about the cheap
design layer that most do not? Is there
a direct implication for how they think
about the hardware strategy specifically
these people?
>> Okay. Um
I I will touch on two points on when it
comes to like the physical AI builders
in this room.
the things that I'm talking about what
does that mean to you so I will touch on
two points one is the extreme code
design across the stack and the second
piece of it is that
u I think the world is going through the
robotic space is going through the same
wave of innovation that we're seeing at
the data center space so let's talk
about the extreme code design when we
look at the
Intel Xeon
32 nanometer the ratio of logic core to
the LLC cache used to be around 70%.
That we had when you look at the die 70%
of the D space was dedicated to logic
cores while the rest was given to more
like SRAMM and cache type of
architectures. But then when you go to
from 32 nanometer to 7 nanometer that
ratio drops to around
uh 20%. Why is that the case is because
like we had less logic per die area
compared to the LLC cache because
at 7 nanometer and below the level of
thermal density that you get
produced by the logic core was so high
that you simply not be able to do the
thermal removal from it as efficiently
as possible. So people put less logic
and they put a lot more cache around the
logic because that takes it's more uh it
has a lot more space around it so it
produces less heat and
uh so they just put more cache around
the logic but then what happened was
with the grace hopper designed by Nvidia
they introduced the liquid cooling
technology that allowed that ratio to go
back up to 70% again. Meaning that a
change at the at the data center
architecture level which was introducing
liquid cooling and instead of air
cooling data centers allowed the
designers the chip designers at the very
low level and instead of being
constrained by the thermal limits uh and
then using less logic to like actually
pack as much as logic while being able
to remove as much as heat as possible.
So let's take that analogy also for the
robotic space where u again on the data
center space we saw that Google went to
design their own TPUs open AAI went to
design the Jalapeno we see that
anthropic is doing a deal with Samsung
to do the next generation of chips as
well
>> and I think this is where the robotics
is also going to go where right now you
guys are using the rock uh the Jen
uh chips you're using the Qualcomm ons
you're using the rock chip and you're
using offtheshelf hardware. But if
you're going to be a successful company,
the lesson that we learned from Steve
Jobs was the best companies in the world
who like build the best products
ultimately build very verticalized
design in a sense that they the way that
they build the best iPhone was
eventually when they went to building or
the best MacBook was when they
eventually like built the M1 chip, the
M2 chip, the M3 chip, fully vertical
integration to build the best product.
This is what Tesla also did. uh this is
what BYD is doing and I think we see we
will see the same thing with robotics
that right now everybody is using
off-the-shelf hardware but my hypothesis
is that if you want to have robotics to
run trillion parameter models with much
more reasoning cap capacity with much
less latency and a lot less power
to like start building custom hardware
and custom ASIC and custom PCB that
gives you an advantage antage a
competitive advantage compared to any
other I guess robotics and physical AI
company out there.
>> This hasn't happened yet because I think
we're still like very much early in this
process. Uh the model architectures are
not set yet the VAS and the VLMs. I
think there's a lot of like change on
that. But in future if we want to have
robots with extremely high reflexivity
I don't think we can like fully rely on
just internet access
uh and just like deal with the kind of
problems that we deal like you your
iPhone when you still like use it it
still struggles with changing network
access between the Wi-Fi the internet
and all of that and if you're just
relying on the cloud to do inference of
intelligence to the robot
uh most likely your robot is going to be
very low quality. The only way you're
going to have the best experience is
when we you can do edge inference and do
vertical integration
of the model and then building custom
ASIC for that. So you have low latency,
low power and high intelligence.
Uh and this is a trend that we will see
very we'll see in the future more and
more of it. If you do that, we're here
to help you guys. We build intelligence
to build electronics and semiconductors.
We have built a hardware team that is on
par with the OpenAI robotics team. A lot
of them were used to be colleagues,
colleagues at Apple. Some of them went
to OpenAI. Some of them came to Voltai.
>> And if you have the ambition, the robot
that you're building, you wanted to uh
build custom PCB, custom async and all
of that. We are here to help you.
>> Awesome, man. That's fantastic. We are
running a little bit out of time, but we
>> Okay, we've answered all the all the
critical questions we wanted to answer
and address.
Thank you so much for coming here from
SF, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Um, so that was a long way. So, ladies
and gentlemen, that was the fun CTO of
Volti. Big applause for him. Thank you
so much for coming again. It was a
pleasure. Thanks for having me. Thank
you.